[Musique]
bonsoir l'être humain n'aime pas le
risque leader j'ai cherché à essayer de
comprendre pourquoi est ce que l'être
humain détester autant le risque alors
je suis allé me promener sur un moteur
de recherche et j'ai tapé le mot prendre
un risque
et voilà les images qu'ils soient
associés au risque à la prise de risque
dans l'imaginaire collectif
là on voit quelqu'un qui est dans une
mauvaise posture sur un fil en train de
tomber dans le vide ou quelqu'un qui a
essayé de sauter d'une falaise dans
l'autre avec à mon avis peu de chance
qu'il arrive de l'autre côté
quelqu'un qui est suspendu dans le vide
et encore quelqu'un qui est là au bout
d'une falaise
peut-être il a l'air de vouloir sauter
mais il ne sait pas trop ce qu'il est en
train de faire alors est ce que ces
photos sont de nature ce soir à vous
inciter à prendre un risque qui envie de
se lancer et prendre un risque ce soir
personne
eh bien oui effectivement nous n'aimons
pas le risque et ce qui est absolument
est étonnant c'est que l'être humain
déploie beaucoup d'énergie et
d'inventivité pour essayer de trouver
des solutions et limiter le risque
voyez toutes les assurances auquel nous
souscrivons nous voulons éviter d'avoir
notre maison qui brûle d'avoir des
événements majeurs qui interviennent et
qui détruisent soudainement nos vies on
veut éviter la maladie donc on souscrit
toutes sortes d'assurances pour arriver
au risque zéro et puis il y à encore
plus innovants on décide de s'injecter
des nanoparticules pour essayer de
repousser le plus loin possible
l'inéluctable soit la mort et on est
même prêt à quoi conférer à des
véhicules autonomes la responsabilité de
conduire à notre place pour éviter le
risque de collision est bien mieux
encore ce soir on a entendu plusieurs
fois le mot intelligence artificielle
nous sommes prêts a conféré à des robots
la tâche de réfléchir à notre place
c'est dire à quel point nous n'aimons
pas le risque
pourtant nos amis anglo-saxons a eu la
prise de risque eh bien il dit sa
tutelle que chase et si le risque était
dans le fond une chance et si le risque
représenté une opportunité
et si nous acceptions d'écouter cette
petite voix intérieure qui vous pousse à
aller vers ce qui représente votre
mission
cette petite voix intérieure en réalité
bien ce sont nos valeurs
ces valeurs qui vont transcender le
risque et ces valeurs qui vont vous
guider vers là où vous devez être votre
mission sur ses terres car on a toutes
et tous une mission sur cette terre les
valeurs et bien ça fait depuis un peu la
nuit des temps qu'on essaie d'en de les
définir déjà à l'antiquité sous les
saules y est bien il y avait dit faire
divers définition qui était donnée de la
notion de valeur là ici je vous cite
shalom schwarz qui est un psychologue
renommer israélien et qui a défini les
valeurs comme des buts désirable qui
doivent servir de principes qui vont
guider la vie des gens alors il a défini
une dizaine de valeurs ou dans lesquels
certainement chacun où se reconnaît ce
soir on voit qu à l universalisme
bienveillance tradition conformité
sécurité on descend vers le pouvoir qui
est également une valeur
l'accomplissement stimulation et de nice
et l'autonomie est ce pas ici s'il se
peut que parfois ces valeurs soient
antagonistes ou que ces valeurs ne
permet tout simplement pas d'avancées
qui est un conflit à ce moment là il va
falloir faire le choix est de voir dans
le fond qu'est ce qui chez vous
absolument non négociable parce que les
valeurs ses petites voix qui sont fond
de vous vous enfouis et bien
lorsqu'elles sont heurtés c'est non
négociable vont avoir plus avancé j'ai
décidé très tôt de devenir avocate
j'ai deux valeurs cardinales qui guide
mon aide et jeux sur lesquels je ne peux
pas négocier
et ça c'est la vie qui me l'a appris par
la suite c'est que je ne supporte pas
l'injustice et que deuxièmement je suis
absolument indépendante c'est-à-dire que
je n'accepte ni qu'on me dise que je
dois faire
ni ce que je dois penser donc cette
indépendance est absolument ancré en moi
j'ai donc décidé de lancer dans la
carrière d'avocate et de défendre celles
et ceux qui commettent des crimes parce
que je suis convaincu que quiconque
quelle que soit la gravité de l'acte
commis mérite d'être défendue et quelle
que soit la noirceur de l'âme il ya
toujours derrière celui qui commet un
crime une raison il faut chercher à
comprendre
alors je me suis lancée dans l'arène
judiciaire je me suis battu j'ai reçu
des coups j'en ai donné je me suis
retrouvé à terre j'ai pleuré lorsque les
personnes que j'ai défend d'être d'un
coup se retrouver condamné à plus de 10
15 17 ans de prison parce que moi
j'avais ce lien avec lui depuis le
premier jour dans le parloir
oui vous explique la vérité peut-être sa
vérité et lorsque l'on se retrouve
devant le tribunal et qu'on se fait le
porte voix de celle ou celui qui est en
prison et bien un moment donné lettre la
justice va trancher et la justice dans
le fond elle est à l'image de celle ou
celui qui va la rendre
elle est imparfaite l'être humain n'est
pas parfait celui qui rend la justice
n'est pas parfait ce qu'on va chercher
par la justice c'est à préserver l'ordre
public c'est à dire qu'on veut éviter
que demain tout le monde commence à tuer
n'importe qui et qu'on veut donner une
sorte de norme sociale qui va être la
référence de ce qui est moral et de ce
qu'il n'est pas moral
c'est ainsi que n'en pouvant plus et ne
supportant pas cette notion de justice
telle qu'elle prévaut dans nos prétoires
j'ai décidé de me tourner vers des
domaines un peu plus technique en me
disant finalement lorsqu'il n'y aura pas
de sentiments derrière tout ça
lorsqu'il n'ya pas des vies humaines qui
sont en jeu j'arriverai à prendre la
distance et puis à défendre donc je me
suis tourné vers des domaines le droit
de l'immobilier l'aménagement du
territoire le droit des
télécommunications
et là je suis rentré dans une zone de
confort j'avais des très beaux dossiers
j'avais des clients qui paient rubis sur
ongle mais au fond de moi j'étais je
sentais que le feu sacré est en train de
disparaître et c'est là où la vie est
revenu tôt camama m'apporte en dix ans
attention ma petite ce n'est pas là haut
tu dois t'arrêter la mission n'est pas
encore terminée et la vie fait que tout
d'un coup il ya des opportunités qui se
présentent
j'ai décidé de me lancer dans les médias
mais ça ne sonnait pas été du jour au
lendemain c'est à dire qu'on m'a proposé
de participer à un concours d'art
oratoire où j'étais destiné à défendre
une des personnalités qui était la
personnalité la plus illustre de ses
deux cent cinquante dernières années
dans le canton de vaud et cette joute
oratoire été filmé par la télévision
et c'est là où j'ai commencé à avoir un
premier pied dans la télévision c'est là
où j'ai commencé à observer je me suis
mais tient finalement si nous devons
utiliser un autre outil un autre moyen
pour rendre justice c'est peut-être ce
qu'ils appellent le quatrième pouvoir le
pouvoir des médias
et pourquoi ne pas utiliser ce pouvoir
pour justement tenter d'éclairer les
consciences et de faire en sorte que le
public est aussi sa voie et qu'on prenne
finalement quels sont les enjeux et de
poires d'une certaine façon influencer
le sort des causes ou bien l'essor des
injustices c'est ainsi que le 8 mars
2015 et lancer une chaîne de télévision
dont le but était justement d'offrir une
tribune de libre expression à celles et
ceux qui portent un regard différent sur
le monde et qui était destiné à offrir
un panorama aussi riche que le monde
dans lequel nous vivons
et là je dois vous dire que c'était
extrêmement difficile comme comme
aventure parce que d'une part yen très
très grosse pression financière que les
investissements sont lourds que les
frais de fonctionnement sont lourds et
qu' il n'y a pas d'autres miracles que
ce que de trouver le moyen de faire
financer tout ça en créant une audience
en monétisant cette audience et en
trouvant des annonceurs qui sont prêts à
venir mettre de la publicité ou à
sponsoriser du contenu sur votre antenne
parce que vous avez créé une l'audience
or qui dit annonceurs dit droit de
regard sur le contenu que vous allez
diffusé l'annonceur qui vient mettre de
la pub sur votre chaîne cherche
l'audience mais il va pas associer son
image à du contenu qui ne serait pas en
accord avec sa position marketing son
positionnement
et donc là je me suis retrouvée
finalement en porte à faux avec une
valeur que je vous ai dit absolument
essentiel chez moi l'indépendance est en
réalité j'étais dans le brouillard le
plus total
je n'arrivais plus à transmettre ma
vision à l'équipe qui avait décidé de me
suivre et je n'arrivais plus à les
motiver c'était absolument devenu
ingérable ya ce moment là quand vous
êtes dans le brouillard
lorsque vous êtes perdus est bien la
seule manière de ne pas perdre pied
c'est de se reconnecter à cette boussole
intérieure qui vous dictent où vous
devez vous rendre aujourd'hui l'aventuré
continue elle se fait sous l'égide d'une
fondation qui est destiné à garantir
l'indépendance des juges du contenu et
qui va nous permettre ainsi de magnifier
l'intelligence collective
alors quand je vous parle de l'illusion
du risque zéro
il ya deux possibilités de voir cela
soit on décide de rester dans sa zone de
confort là où on est bien où on se dit
que finalement à tous tout bien
considéré et bien c'est pas si mal que
ça mais où progressivement on sent qu'il
ya une partie de nous qui est en train
de s'éteindre
ou alors on décide de prendre
l'opportunité ce risque qui s'offrent à
vous comme une chance et se dire que
finalement ce risque c'est la porte le
sésame pour aller se connecter en son
for intérieur à ces valeurs et ces
valeurs qui vont vous amener là où vous
devez aller moi j'ai décidé comme je
vous ai dit d'être le porte-voix des
voix qu'on entend pas et ses expériences
dans le bar ou dans les médias m'amène
vers ma troisième entreprise une
entreprise qui va me permettre justement
d'assurer cette mission je pense que là
je suis le plus en valeur avec ce que
j'ai entrepris jusqu'à présent parce que
les gens ne sont pas connectés au bon
réseau parce qu'ils ne sont pas
forcément bon endroit y attend de voir
qui mérite d'être entendue parce que le
message qu'elle comporte sont absolument
essentielle non seulement pour elle mais
pour l'humanité
il y absolument important et primordial
de permettent d'amplifier ces messages
qui sont essentiels pour l'humanité de
manière exponentielle
donc nous créons une plateforme digitale
qui va permettre d'amplifier avec le
soutien du public de manière
exponentielle ces messages afin qu'ils
atteignent l'audience qu'ils doivent
atteindre et qu' ils soient enfin
entendues pour déployer tous leurs
effets et donc moi j'ai juste envie de
vous dire ce soir
prenez saisissez le risque qui va se
présenter sur votre route comme une
opportunité
et surtout n'oubliez pas que vous n'avez
rien à perdre a risqué et je vous
encourage le faire tous et tout ce soir
voilà merci
[Applaudissements]